the girag and experience and and hope of
an afterlife is yes yes that is the
purpose and meaning right yeah yes I
suppose that's right yes I think that's
that's right I can understand why people
might want to believe a priest who comes
along and tells them you don't have to
worry about death because you're going
to survive it I'm less understanding of
people who make up stories to comfort
either themselves or other people I mean
a made up story should not be comforting
I didn't understand how a made up story
can be comforting of course if you make
it up and persuade somebody else then
they could find it comforting on the
other hand is an afterlife really all
that comforting when you think about
half of them believe they're going to go
to hell so is anything but comforting
and also even if you're not going to
hell if you're going to heaven eternity
in heaven I mean sitting up sitting in
in heaven for not just billions of years
but trillions of years I mean these are
these are time spans beyond our
comprehension how unbelievably boring it
would be what it though I mean I don't
know I I enjoy life but if I had to live
my life over and over again infinitely
if I had an infinite number of this
exact lives
I don't know how I'd approach that in
the moment I can enjoy it I could do it
maybe 200 years but after that now I
mean I think I think that eternity is
what's frightening about death and
eternity is best spent under local under
a general anesthetic mmm is what's gonna
happen right gonzo alcohol the lights
maybe yeah
or maybe not have you had any experience
with psychedelics yeah no you have any
interest in that I've been offered to be
accompanied on a trip by a very nice
woman friend yeah
and I've never so far dared take her up
on it
how come I asked advice of a cousin of
my father who just recently died who was
a major expert on psychedelics and
I think he was the one who introduced
Aldous Huxley to met mescaline for
example and he judiciously advised
against he said that the horrors of a
bad trip are so awful that he wouldn't
he wouldn't advise somebody to go into
it my friend who is offering me this
this trip says it would be a relatively
low dose and she would take another low
dose so she could kind of accompany me
no don't leave jumping out a window or
anything well there's so many stories in
so many ancient religions it seemed to
originate with the consumption of some
some sort of a psychedelic yes and you
know there's many including John Marco
Oleg grows the sacred mushrooms Jesus
Jesus was a much yes yes so I mean it I
mean you could see the connection if you
were a primitive person with no access
to science and you found some mushroom
growing under a tree and consumed didn't
have this unbelievable experience you
would assume that you've transcended
this life and gone into this other realm
where God exists I once thought that I
would try a psychedelic when I was on my
deathbed that's it but what if it was
amazing you know like I could have
gotten so much done with this okay if I
had maybe try this out when I was thirty
yes maybe right I I don't you know I
don't think anybody should do anything I
mean I used to I used to encourage
people to do things all the time now my
thought is do whatever compels you
whenever you feel like it but I would
think that a person like yourself who
has this sort of rigorous belief that
the lights go out and then that's it I
would think that that would be
attractive to just at least dip your
toes in yes
yes well don't you think the lights go
out I don't know you know I don't know
I've had some pretty profound
psychedelic experiences that make me
wonder what what thoughts are and what
what consciousness is and whether or not
there's some way that it transcends well
I wonder what consciousness is but it's
pretty clear that it's to do with brains
and brains decay and so I I wouldn't
know that much hope for you well you
might be right yeah you might be well
certainly consciousness does have to do
with brains and we know brain damage so
really perturbed consciousness but
there's some interaction with certain
chemicals and that makes this experience
far different than what it is when we're
on the natch little brains there mm-hmm
yeah steel brain but that's it
reductionist I think we wrong with
reductionism nothing wrong with it
you're not saying there is
[Applause]